[Music]
the subtitle of our book is finding
Cassandra's to stop catastrophes
Cassandra in Greek mythology was someone
cursed by the gods who could accurately
see the future but would never be
believed when we say Cassandra's
throughout the book we're talking about
people who can accurately see the future
people who are right Cassandra was right
people who are right about the future
but are being ignored having derived
what we think are the lessons learned
from past Cassandra events we then
looked at people today who were
predicting things and being ignored we
looked at issues first and then tried to
see if there was someone warning about
them so the book is about people 14
people 7 who we know were Cassandra's
and 7 who we are examining to find out
if they are usually Cassandra's are
people who are not directly involved in
the thing that they worry about there
are people who observe it and there are
people who study it but in the case of
Jennifer Duden them at the University of
California Berkeley she's the person who
created it and she's also our Cassandra
the it in this case is crisper cast line
a method that she invented and I'm sure
someday we'll get a Nobel Prize for a
method of doing gene editing that allows
for removal of genetic defects in the
strain or addition into a strain of new
capabilities now this is going to
revolutionize human life it's already
beginning it's going to mean that all
the genetic defects that have caused so
much pain and suffering for people for
millions of years all of that could
potentially be removed so why does the
great woman who invented this wake up in
the middle of the night worrying about
it what she told us was
she's afraid that she might have become
dr. Frankenstein that the technique that
she developed could be misused in
horrible ways it could be misused for
example to create biological weapons to
create new forms of threats to human
beings threats for which we don't have
any known antidote or it could simply be
used to create human beings of far
superior capability not just taking
genes and removing defects but adding
new super capabilities so one scenario
we discussed with her was one if the
North Koreans or the Chinese decided
that they would create super soldiers
physically large people with great
athletic ability designed to be soldiers
designed to be aggressive designed to be
able to fight for long periods of time
or once they simply created people who
were brilliant at computer programming
and had IQs off the charts what if in
the process of that kind of gene editing
we created a caste society where some
people were genetically designed to do
menial tasks and didn't have the
capability of doing anything else
and other people were designed to be the
rulers with huge IQs and the capability
of understanding things beyond the pale
for lesser humans that's something that
scared the creator of Chris Burke as 9
and it scared us when we heard
Jennifer's story we asked ourselves does
she fit the template of a Cassandra that
we developed in the first half of the
book looking at the the first seven is
she an expert absolutely she is the
expert she created it
is she dated driven yes she has a wealth
of data on Christopher Castle on and
what it can do
is she predicting something that is
first a current syndrome something
that's never happened before and the
answer that is yes is it kind of
outlandish it's the stuff of Hollywood
fiction yes it is what about the
audience the decision-maker one of the
things we saw with the earlier
Cassandra's was wasn't always clear that
there was a decision-maker people always
pointed at each other saying that's your
job or at least it's not my job and in
this case making decisions about what
gene-editing can happen and can't happen
and enforcing that as a matter of law
and international law it's not all clear
whose job that is one of those issues we
looked at was artificial intelligence
now frankly my co-author RP Eddie and I
disagreed about whether or not to do
artificial intelligence I said I don't
think this is a problem after all if a
computer acts up you can unplug it
obviously I didn't understand the issue
and the way that my co-author RP Eddie
convinced me that we should look for
someone on this issue was by saying who
are the people who are talking about
this today not the experts in AI the
people who are generally concerned about
it and who were they Bill Gates the
founder of Microsoft Elon Musk the
founder of Tesla Steven Hawkings the
great physicist from Oxford and when I
heard that I said okay fine maybe those
guys think this is a problem maybe we
should look for the expert who is
predicting that this could be a future
disaster and we found Elliott Kowski who
not only thinks this could become a
disaster he's dedicated his life and all
of his work to dealing with the future
threat of artificial intelligence
because he doesn't think it's inevitable
that artificial intelligence should
a problem but he does have a scenario
whereby it could be if we don't do some
of the things he has in mind what's the
problem problem could be that artificial
intelligence starts writing software
complex software maybe even encrypted
software that human beings do not
understand and can't deal with that
future is just around the corner already
we have software writing software
already at Google we have artificial
intelligence writing software for
further artificial intelligence and the
Google program is getting to the point
where they're afraid they don't fully
understand how it's doing what it's
doing but only eight cows keep fears
most is that super intelligence will
come into existence
that means artificial intelligence
programs that are significantly smarter
than human intelligence and even human
intelligence today augmented by
computers and what he sees as possible
looking at the rate of advanced in
technology is that this will not be a
linear growth in the capabilities of
software but it could be overnight one
day
artificial intelligence might be under
the control of human beings and the next
day it might have jumped into super
intelligence far more capable than
anything we could possibly understand if
you then put artificial intelligence
onto networks that are running critical
infrastructure the Internet of Things
another subject we look at in the book
it's possible in the worst case scenario
that human beings will lose control of
the infrastructure of society in even
worse case scenarios than that
artificial intelligence will decide he
doesn't need humans at all and it is
that fear that causes him
propose that we agree now as a planet as
a number of different countries and
societies to put limits on the
development of artificial intelligence
and to do that by international treaty
and to have observation to make sure
that artificial intelligence doesn't
break out of predetermined limits agreed
by human beings and their governments
now you've seen that plot before you've
seen that in a Hollywood movie and
that's part of the problem with so many
of the possible Cassandra's then we
looked at today that humans have seen
these threats before they saw them in
science fiction so whether it's the
possibility of an asteroid hitting the
earth or human beings being genetically
engineered or artificial intelligence
taking over part of the reason we don't
take these Cassandra's seriously is
we've seen it in the movies we've seen
it in science fiction a corollary issue
to artificial intelligence is the rise
of robotics and already in this country
we're hearing debates about the
possibility that the next wave in
automation rather than just shifting
jobs from one function to another which
has been what's happened in the past
with automation may be the next wave of
automation would be far more advanced
and complex and actually throw humans
out of work it's a debate that's going
on and we don't know who's right
some people say people will be thrown
out of work and there will be less need
for humans to do work and we'll have to
pay humans for doing nothing tacks
computers is one proposal tax robots is
a proposal and the other theory is that
just as in the past when technology
advances it may displace certain jobs
but it will create new ones
we don't know who's right there but we
do know
all of our future Cassandra's are our
present-day Cassandra's predicting
things about the future that they need
to be listened to and there needs to be
examination of the theories that they're
putting forward in the data that they're
putting forward even if they are an
outlier a minority view among experts
[Music]